Oh key dokey let's get started with
today's video
hey everyone how's it going hope you are
well today we're going to be talking
about learning the more you know so
questions I get often in my DMS or
questions like how do you stay
up-to-date with new technologies or how
do you stay relevant with the tech
industry when things are moving so fast
so we're gonna hit on three things today
whether it's true that you always need
to stay up-to-date with new technologies
to stay relevant my own experience is
with it and if it is true and if it's
not a myth how to go about doing it and
how to think about it let's get started
so it's no secret that new technologies
are coming out all the time when new
technologies are always coming out it is
kind of true that you do have to stay up
to date with new technologies but it's
also true that not everyone is an expert
in every new technology and a lot of
software engineers and most companies
will not adopt these new technologies as
soon as they come out or even two to
five years out and personally I think
that one of the best and also scariest
things about being a software engineer
is precisely this that you're always
going to be learning as a software
engineer and I also want to note that
always learning doesn't necessarily mean
that you're always learning new
technologies you're always just learning
new skills and we're gonna touch on that
in a little bit but before we do that I
wanted to just kind of talk about almost
the essence of software engineering and
I think the essence is that you're
always failing it's literally a career
about failing learning from your
failures and gaming skills and doing
better next time
if you think about how software is
always iterative I think it's just based
on that precipice of you're always going
to fail and you're always going to make
mistakes but there's so much to learn
from all of those mistakes that you can
do better next time I think it's also
based on the fact that there's nothing
perfect in software engineering there's
no perfect line of code there's no
perfect software engineer there's no
perfect application or code base for
those of you who do have experience
diving into existing code bases you know
that there's a lot of dust bunnies and
weird architectural decisions and just
lots of cruft that exists I know that
whenever I start a new job I'm like
your app is great like it's so stable
and it's probably made so well and then
I peek behind the covers and I'm like
what is this miss this makes no sense
and I think you'll just find that at all
the roles nothing is perfect and
software engineering so once you realize
that nothing is perfect then also you
realize that oh it's totally okay to
make mistakes and fail and just learn
from your failures because there's just
so much to learn all the time now it
took a little bit for me to wrap my head
around the fact that I'm always gonna be
failing so I just want to take us back
to like my first job as a software
engineer where I was doing iOS
development now I hadn't really done any
meaningful amount of iOS development
before that like I made an app once with
some people of which I wrote maybe a
couple lines of code so I knew that in
my first role I would need to do a lot
of learning I had no idea how to use
Xcode I barely wrote Objective C and so
that's the thing that I really focused
on in my first couple of years so that's
exactly what I did I told my manager hey
I know nothing please help me learn
something so that I can be a valuable
software engineer and contribute to the
codebase and the team and the
application and I just really wanted to
be exposed to lots of different parts of
iOS development in all the different
areas of software development web
development security gaming development
you can go so so deep into each area and
within each area there's lots of other
little areas there's just the whole
world to learn basically in each thing
and that's exactly what my manager did
he assigned me books to read he told me
some courses to take as well as some
tutorials to do and also I found mentors
within my team who could also guide me
through all of this too and I really
can't emphasize enough how much I didn't
know at the beginning but once I
realized and told myself and told others
and was honest with myself like yo I
don't know stuff that's where the
learning began because I was willing to
accept the fact that you know I'm a
failure right now but I can get myself
out of this by learning new skills and
yes the beginning was very very hard
I remember my very first bug bash which
is worse where we all sit together and
just resolve a bunch of bugs and sitting
there being like I don't I don't know
how to do any of this cuz I don't know
what I'm doing and I can barely read a
gypsy and always being faced with what a
little I knew was tough but those are
the little failure points that I turned
into motivation to learn new skills and
then after a while maybe about six
months to a year I looked back and I was
like you know I actually know some stuff
especially compared to my first week on
the job and I'm really proud of myself
for putting in that work and accepting
the fact that you know I don't know a
whole lot and I need to learn a lot more
and now I do know a lot more and I feel
way more competent as an engineer and I
know a lot more about iOS development I
mean a big part of this is just reaching
out for help and asking people and
telling people like yo help me I don't
know what I'm doing so that was kind of
my experience as an early career
software engineer just absorbing
everything about the technology and now
I'm gonna get to the point where I
mentioned earlier about learning other
skills that are also really important so
after I felt like I had a good grasp of
iOS development maybe that was about
like two years later I realized that
there aren't really other paved paths
past this point it was all just about
figuring out what I wanted to get better
at what I failed at and realizing from
there the skills that I want and need in
order to progress towards a place that I
want to be now this all sounds vague and
ambiguous but really what I'm trying to
say is things like product skills people
skills creativity skills writing skills
these are all important skills to
software engineering that I didn't
realize we're important at the beginning
and actually I would argue that in order
to become a really well-rounded software
engineer it's not just about the
technical skills you need all of the
other skills in order to do a good job
for instance the people skills that I've
worked on have enabled me to talk about
technology to non-technical people and
has really translated to like the
content that I make
on here which I enjoy doing I mean if
we're being really honest if you told me
in my first year working that I would
eventually make a YouTube channel about
software engineering I'd be like no
that's not happening but here we are
because I mean I realized that I just
want to do this and it would be fun so
here I am thanks for subscribing if
you're not subscribed click on the
subscribe button and I realize at this
point when there were all these other
skills that I would need to learn to be
the best person and software engineer I
could be I realized that there's really
a merit to being a lifelong learner as a
software engineer and I think that is
the really important lesson here yes is
the software engineering means you're
always failing but in order to overcome
that you just have to be a lifelong
learner and the best news is anybody can
be a lifelong learner you just have to
have that kind of like I'm okay to fail
I accept that I fail I'm going to figure
out how not to feel the next time and
understand what you need to learn to do
better so you might be asking what does
this actually look like like how do
software engineers actually learn the
skills that they need to learn and well
honestly everybody's different some
people set aside a certain amount of
time every week to learn stuff other
people take time off to do it and learn
it on weekends but for me I am a very
like Purpose Driven learner in a sense
that I learned the best when there is a
bigger goal that I want to achieve so
that I can do some purposeful learning
in order to build the skills to get to
where I want to go so when it comes to
software if there's like an app that I
want to build or feature idea that I
have then usually that will kind of be
my bigger goal and I will go through
tutorials read books watch videos to
figure out what skills and things I need
to learn in order to get that job done
and sometimes that job is literally just
like feeding my curiosity the other day
I was like what the heck is blockchain
and then I watched some videos on it and
I feel like I have a better grasp on
what it is and now when people talk
about blockchain I'm like
I know what that is now and as I
mentioned before as a person I'm always
thinking about Who am I where do I want
to go what are my current circumstances
where can I go
what skills do I need to get there so
that I make the best use of my time here
on this earth in this body not
existential at all and I mean it's also
because as a person it's really hard to
define exactly what you want to be and
who you want to be because these days
there's really no one right way to do
life and it's just full of a myriad of
experiences that you wouldn't have
predicted would happen at all so I guess
what I'm trying to say is I like to keep
it open and did and instead I really
just let my curiosity fuel my learning
and I don't know how to trigger
curiosity I just I just get curious and
then I'm just like I'm gonna learn it so
no tips there so I'm not the type to
like schedule time to learn stuff I
don't set aside X amount of hours to
learn about this new framework or
anything I will maybe if I'm very
curious about that framework find a
project that will help me use that
project basically but yeah having a
purpose helps me stay motivated in
learning stuff and it means a lot of
failing and a lot of hard stuff along
the way to figure out what I need to do
and accepting the fact that I suck at a
lot of stuff but I mean that's how you
learn and that is ultimately I feel like
how you become a lifelong learner I mean
it really it's a little it's kind of a
lesson on humility I think and the best
part is that the Internet has opened up
so many new ways of learning and
consuming content because of all the
amazing content creators out there I
personally learned the best from video
content so I'm really happy to say that
Skillshare has kindly sponsored this
video today for those of you who don't
know Skillshare is an online learning
community with over 25,000 classes on
everything from design to web
development to business to lifestyle
stuff literally anything you want to
learn it's on Skillshare since I've been
doing I allotment for like my whole
entire career I've been really curious
about web development
I found this awesome course by
Christopher Dodd on Skillshare called
understanding web development a
beginner's guide to the web it talks
everything about the difference between
front-end and back-end as well as things
like CSS JavaScript HTML really the
foundational stuff that's really
important to get started in what
development I also really like this
other class that I took called
discovering success 7 exercises to incur
your purpose passion and path by Emma
Gannon so taking this class with really
interactive materials and in video form
is the best place for me to learn and I
hope it will help you all to I mean if
you think about the fact that you don't
have to go back to college or take
in-person classes to learn anymore it
really opens up the opportunities and
places for you to learn stuff so I'm
really happy that Skillshare exists I
feel like I'm juggling a lot of stuff
all the time and finding a good place
and good resources to learn things that
I know nothing about like skill sure is
an awesome place to do that they also
have a lot of courses in software
development
so be sure to check that out as well as
all of the other like non-technical
skills that are also really important as
a software engineer and skill sure is
giving away a free two month unlimited
access trial for my subscribers who
click the link in the description box
down below and it's only about ten
dollars a month after that so definitely
be sure to check that out thank you
again
Skillshare you're awesome I love
education and learning platforms and
stuff like my parents are both teachers
so I'm really excited that they
sponsored so thank you alright I hope
you like this video give it a thumbs up
if you did and subscribe and hit the
bell notification or leave a comment
down below you know the drill um I just
want to hear from you all about how
you're doing okay that's it for today I
hope you have a great day wherever you
are and let's get learning
[Music]